President Trump goes to Florida this
morning to spend the holidays at his
mar-a-lago resort a senior White House
official says the president may sign the
tax bill before he leaves Washington he
celebrated his first major piece of
legislation with congressional
Republicans at the White House on
Wednesday the new president dominated
the year in politics with his challenges
on the job together we will make America
great again
Russia is a ruse I have nothing to do
with Russia the Russia story is a total
fabrication
there was no collusion there was no
nothing if it's possible would you let
me know am i under investigation is that
you are not under investigation
regardless of recommendation I was going
to fire call me we condemn in the
strongest possible terms this egregious
display of hatred bigotry and violence
on many sides one many sides I hit him
with everything I got the white
supremacist the neo-nazi I got them all
in them Rocketman is on a suicide
mission for himself and for his regime
we're gonna repeal and replace Obamacare
nobody knew that health care could be so
complicated
they said Mitch get to work and let's
get it done they lost by one vote for a
thing like that to happen is it disgrace
all Ryan admit she was a little team we
just got together and we would work very
hard didn't we it seems like there was a
lot of fun it's always a lot of fun when
you win so what does the president's
first year tell us about where we're
heading in 2018 Susan page is USA
TODAY's Washington bureau chief good
morning hey good morning let's talk
first about this Russia investigation
you hear from those on Capitol Hill say
this may be the most important
investigation where might the special
counsel head in the new year well we
know he's doing he's been talking to a
lot of people we we get leaks out of
various aspects of the investigation not
so much from the Special Counsel himself
that lead us to believe that there is a
he's moving toward looking at whether
there was either collusion or
obstruction of justice by the White
House by the President himself by
members of his family by campaign and
other aides this is back cast a huge
shadow over the White House this year
and that shadow is only gonna get deeper
and stronger I think as we go into this
new year there's enough there's been a
5,000 point rise in the stock market
this year unemployment's at 4% but the
president's approval rating is at 35%
how is that and what a disconnect that
is because typically if the economy is
doing well then the president's approval
rating goes up that's not been the case
this time and those who disapprove of
the president cite not so much his
treatment of the economy his handling of
the economy they cite his character and
his judgment and those are hard things
to change you know one thing that's
different with this president than
previous modern presidents is he has
failed to expand the group of Americans
that support him or the thinkwell of him
in his first year in fact that his
support has actually declined his
approval rating is now significantly
lower than any other president in modern
times at this point in his tenure I've
heard you say that President Trump in
his election helped fuel though the me2
movement what do you mean by that
because I think many people give Harvey
Weinstein credit for this yes I think
not one factor that accounts for a big
cultural shift that we're seeing in this
country now but when President Trump was
elected despite credible allegations of
sexual misconduct on his part I think
some people thought this would set a new
lower bar for sexual harassment and
sexual harassment in the workplace and
instead I think it's had the reverse
effect it's really stoked the movement
that of women becoming very public and
being more willing to talk about sexual
harassment in the workplace and
encouraged others to take them seriously
to believe them and that has been I
think one of the unexpected consequences
of the Trump president you know Susan
you've covered so many elections and as
we look towards this midterm election
we're hearing now that even the
Republican National Committee is warning
the Trump White House that there could
be a bloodbath in the 2018 elections in
part driven by women voters yes it's so
interesting you know I think Democrats
are increasingly optimistic they will
win control of the house and Republicans
are increasingly pessimistic that that
in fact is going to happen that we'll
see
four seats flip so that Democrats regain
control of the house and some of that is
driven by this new activism no
engagement by Women Voters we've seen
that in the elections that we've had in
this past year in in New Jersey and in
Alabama and in Virginia and also the
engagement of women not only as voters
but as candidates emily's list now says
that 25,000 women have contacted them
interested in running for office at
various levels 25,000 astounding numbers
so how do you how do you assess his
first year so I think in terms of policy
he's had a huge impact you know I think
that in terms of appointments to the
federal courts in terms of repealing
regulations this new tax bill he has had
President Trump can count things he has
succeeded in doing that he said he was
going to do but politically he is on a
very perilous path and that goes to the
midterm elections and to this Russia
investigation being interesting year
ahead Susan page thank you thank you